herzlich willkommen zur aktuellen
sitzung des seminars oder philosophische
evolutionstheorie in der heutigen
sitzung soll es um die frage gehen
inwiefern emotionen als gefühle urteile
und motive aufgefasst werden können
darum soll es heute geben und wir gehen
dann auch mit nur eine diskussion wie
verhalten sich emotionen zu gefühlen
sieht sie dasselbe sind sie nur eine
klasse von gefühlen haben gefühle haben
wir nur zuhören gefühl zweite die
verhalten sich emotionen zu urteilen
wir sehen hier wird es schon rationaler
wie verhalten sich emotionen zum
tieferen motivation und fern sind
emotionen rational sind emotionen nicht
nur gefühle die subjektiv sind die gar
nichts kognitives ausdrücken er nur
beliebigen willkürliche individuelle
zustände darstellen die keine
verbindlichkeit haben
niefern sind seien objektiv das sind
emotionen auch inter subjektiv gültig
oder gelten sie mal für das individuum
was sie hat das sind die fragen die man
uns heute stellen und zwar stellen wir
uns diese fragen an dieses wirklich
wichtigen artikels emotion fonds
garantien und dessous und diesen artikel
habe ich dann unten nach einem youtube
video verlinkt der ist kostenlos zu
können überdies zu erhalten sie die
opfer los ja diese artikel werden jetzt
diese drei dimensionen emotionen als
gefühle emotionen als urteile und
emotionen als motive oder motivation
diskutiert in aller kürze und das möchte
ich jetzt im heutigen video das mit
präsentieren und dann werden wir darüber
diskutieren
als ich zitiere mal es geht jetzt um
emotionen und gefühle emotionen als
gefühle industrie oder social sentry
most common sense ist der emotions aus
dem werk las noch viel inc die fronten
bei der experience qualität von aricent
sense experience leittechnik und proprio
6 mpi in münster wolbeck
dirigierte die morgens angst ist weg
sagte kiriasis dominierte die motion
serie für manchester beginnen auf der
trendset also was hier gesagt das ist
die einfachste theorie den emotionen
die militärs die theorie dies sagt
einfach emotionen sind nur eine klasse
eine art von gefühlen und die emotionen
als gefühl unterscheiden sich nur durch
die adern und qualität also schokoladen
gefühl ein gefühl des schokoladen
geschmacks einer sinneseindruck wäre ein
gefühl und ein schmerzempfinden wären
gefühlen
das sind also nur zurückgeben tiefe
erfahrungen
das ist also die ganz ganz generell
differenzierte sicht man kann das jetzt
so darstellen
ein gefühl das es also die oberklasse
sozusagen und darunter fallen jetzt
emotionen darunter fallen effekte
darunter können stimmungen fallen und
vielleicht sogar noch antreffen
das wäre als du diese standardtheorie
wir haben jetzt unserem seminar ich nach
oben rechts den link zur zweiten sie zum
rhein hier schon gute gründe dafür
angeführt dass gefühle nicht mit
emotionen zu identifizieren sind das
also diese anordnung nicht überzeugen
müssen dass wir emotionen gefühle
effekte stimmung auf diese ebene setzen
müssen als phänomene der eigenen ab dass
wir hier möglichkeiten haben sie
voneinander zu dem schreiben darauf
kommt auch in diesem seminar bis anders
an
so jetzt weiteres zitat immer noch zu
der frage stellung ob emotionen gefühle
sind
ich wünsche mir lief gut mit difficult
to explain why they can be justified in
light of these dass niemand über die
hauptquest users to the sense experience
of tasty zottel und viele pains in
europa
also wenn emotionen jetzt nur gefühle
klären wie es diesen standard dies wurde
mit ihrer theorie
dann könnten wir nicht rechtfertigen wir
können keine gründe warum das so ist
doch nicht anders also wir hätten keinen
rationalen zugang dazu
nur subjektiv ist und es gibt gute
gründe warum eben emotionen durchaus mit
gründen und vernunft in einem einer
beziehung stehen weiteres zitat jetzt
aber zur frage wie sich emotionen und
urteile zueinander verhalten wir sehen
jetzt hier schon jetzt wird die sache
rationaler evolution als gefühle
betrafen nicht so sehr die rationalität
ein urteil hingegen ist etwas was
relativ betrifft relativ iris of
emotions and cognitive function
campaigns gefühl aus dem effektiv 16
teams und kaminski die station ist die
queen contador und co sind relativ ziel
ist konstitutiv juli startet die
möglichen kommissions ovations partikel
kein space security measures erst bei
publisher relations aufbaute glück
kannst du nicht kennst du wieder
verlassen wollte kassel prozent des
niveaus und polizei konnte also jetzt
haben wir hier einen kognitiven zugang
der über palliative theorien von
emotionen beschreibt und hier können wir
jetzt eben dass sich konstitutiven und
kameraden theorie konstitutiven theorien
über inflation also urteile
argumentieren dass emotionen eben
kommissionen sind oder bewertung ein
koalition eine evolution ist immer eine
kombination der denken gedacht der
äußern wir pro position also dass etwas
[Musik]
sozialer theorien argumentieren dass
musikkompositionen zumindest verursacht
sind als die folgen aus konventionen
auch wenn die streng genommen keine
rationale struktur haben aber immerhin
von kombination abhängig sind als eine
folge und deswegen irgendwie noch mit
patienten verdienen stehen
jetzt können wir weitere sagen in diesem
artikel zitierte die argument großen
auch für den nächsten film ocean's
thirteen verlust mit der alternastage
auf den projekten ist der college in
motion ist pro projekt justin case jetzt
formel a tec ist in sands edith budde
feelings an orte kein springs wird kein
ende
inter konzept relations reform ab jetzt
sollte die pupille gebärdet in
konzeption relations officer emotions
methode toribio auf kognitiver nation
auf sein kannst also hier sind wichtiger
begriff ins spiel gekommen nämlich schon
alle die internationalität bedeutet dass
emotionen auf einem gegenstand gerichtet
sie haben einen ein formales objekt also
nur jetzt das objekt ist das ist
irgendwie bedingungen die objektiv sind
und dass natürlich würde sie in eine
diese nähe zur vernunft
das würde sie irrational verständlich
machen weitere argumente zur frage nach
emotionen und brutalen und kein of
cognitive evaluation der maus über das
type of companies tier i von ross stores
mit der die vereinigung zusammen
jetzt gibt es hier einige gegenwärtige
philosophen aber zoll am montmartre lust
bei optimaler nußbaum wird die meisten
teilnehmenden vertraut sein täglicher
pro kann sie sagen
emotionen sind dasselbe wie urteile
ankommen interpretation auf der you mein
engel zusammen
die ist george mental health person
der general ist die moschee jackman ist
insgesamt wächst ja das ist die frage
ist jetzt wirklich eine revolution
dasselbe wie ein urteil das beispiel ist
meine wut auf jemanden gut
ist das überhaupt eine evolution ich bin
hier skeptisch aber gut meine wut auf
niemanden ist dasselbe oder besteht in
dem urteil das ich von dieser person
falsch plage wurde geht darin die wut
auf nur den vorteil dass wir glauben
ich wurde von dieser person nicht nicht
fair behandelt
ich glaube nicht ich glaube dass die
wurde erstens keine emotion ist ein
effekt ist und wenn sie eine emotion ist
das dann auch eine gewisse gefühl seite
eine große rolle spielen mussten ihn
nicht so was wie eine motivation dass
ihr vielleicht sogar der person an den
kragen wollen dass ich auch dieses boot
körperlich zeit bestimmte merkmale wie
zähneknirschen oder ende fäuste ballen
und so weiter ich glaube das greift zu
kurz
jetzt können wir uns noch die frage
stellen mir fern emotionen motive sind
traditionen des thalia film ocean's
kingdom century us special cars of
motivation states international state
braugerste den channel cause of health
and sz ist eine go wenn man das auf
dessen research verglichen findet sample
problem nach vier teams interessiert ist
explaining why did what we do personelle
konsequenzen
also jetzt haben wir noch zur ergänzung
der emotions theorie als gefühl das
urteil noch die theorie dass emotionen
motivationen darstellen also die denken
emotionen sind immer auch auf
verhandlungen bezogen und das eben
handlungen immer eine emotion brauchen
um überhaupt verzogen werden zu können
das heißt eine motivation und ich denke
das ist sicherlich überzeugend emotionen
sind motive für unsere handlungen nicht
nur sind auch gründe also in dieser
auffassung von emotionen als motive
haben wir immer auch die latente
rationalität enthalten nämlich die
gründe wir können das begründen anders
jetzt als wie ich glaube jedenfalls im
affekt wo wir nicht immer ganz klar die
motive kontrollieren und geradezu
nachvollziehen können sondern im affekt
da geschieht einfach etwas minister
werden der überwältigt deswegen glaube
ich dass effekte nicht so sehr als
motivation zumindest rational zu
gleichen in der kratzer zu welcher art
angesehen werden sollten noch weiter ist
die tat zu fragen ich revolution mit
motivation sind motivationssystem ist
die effektive tomkins kostet der a9
basic effekt bei den herd programms in
christo germans preis 4
distress content andys gast den
motivation power kannst du viel honig
feelings im märchen von the press
section of fashion changing the way back
ja jetzt wird hier wieder das wort
effekt genannt
also hier wird jetzt nicht streng
unterschieden zwischen emotion perfekten
und ihr wird eine ganze reihe von
möglichen kandidaten angeführt in quest
ich weiß nicht ob es überhaupt ein
gefühl ist wenn frist nicht irgendwann
kognitiver zustand dass das interesse
ist es nicht nur ein aufmerksamkeit die
auf einen gegenstand gerichtet werden
häufig geht interesse natürlich auch mit
emotionalen zustände in träumen genuss
sicherlich sonderpreis überraschung ja
ist überraschender unserer theorie jetzt
eine emotion vielleicht ihren effekt
können wir nachher doppel diskutieren
vier furcht ist vom charme haben wir
jedenfalls auch als den motionen 2
programm jedenfalls in einer lösung
studierten form verachtung
das geht dann auch in richtung von hass
da haben wir darüber diskutiert und das
ist ein möglicher kandidat von nutzern
also emotionen haben eine emotionale
emotionale kraft die eben daraus
resultiert dass sie ihrer gefühls
dimension als etwas angenehmes oder
etwas schmerzhaftes kommentiert sind
aber ich denke das ist unstrittig
und jetzt bringt dieser artikel den ich
eben ihnen heute zum letzten mal
präsentieren wollen will weil wir in der
nächsten sitzung denn auf die einzelnen
historischen positionen eingehen eine
zusammenfassung nicht jedes mal vor
das sind jetzt zehn punkte dieses finde
ich sollte man sich wo zu gemüte führen
und auch diskutieren ersten social soll
es in wolfegg liest im protokoll cases
rebelliert für seeleute köpfen
königsklasse baby oder und mentor
komponenten auszutauschen
[Musik]
also etwa eine palliative dimensionen
physiologisch es heißt also eine
körperliche außen dringe die dimension
eine phänomenologische das heißt diese
emotionen kann genauer als phänomen
geschrieben werden ihre internen
strukturen expressiv expressiv hängt
jetzt gegen mit dem physiologischen
zusammen muss aber nicht nur das
körperliche in großdruck ausgerichtet
sein geheimnis so das verhalten
vielleicht jetzt in einem weiteren sinne
als nur physiologisch gefasst und mental
wir haben gesehen mentale zu tun gibt es
wenn es um gründe geht wenn es ein
urteil gibt
ich glaube dass das eine ziemlich gute
generell beschreibung ist dieser
zweitens kann er bis auf 10 414
manifeste creative intenso die ration
andy schlecks müssen wir unterscheiden
zwischen type und trocken
der unterschied besteht im folgenden ein
teil ist also ein thema es gibt also zb
die emotionen der furcht ein tötet
emotionsarmen genau ist und jetzt gibt
es auch noch trocken trocken sind
sozusagen vorkommnisse des typs als wir
können innerhalb des typs verschiedene
konkrete formen unterscheiden wo kommen
nicht sozusagen und hier lässt lassen
sich weitere differenzierungen anbringen
auch die tensid die dauer und so weiter
der bereich der intendierten objekte
drittens kurze ts emotions and enjoy the
present ich glaube dass das überzeugende
emotionen wenn wir sehr komplexes
phänomen fassen die repräsentieren etwas
heißt sie richten sich auch auf ein
gegenstand den sie repräsentieren ein
objekt was repräsentieren sie das müssen
wir uns immer fragen
ich denke aber das ist die gute
antworten darauf gibt für musicals of
emotions the brand new york jets mit
konstant one to one with any vorteil in
brand ein brandmeldealarm endet alles
zentral tour der kampf an
niemand von uns denke ich wird
bestreiten dass emotionen ihren grund
ihre physikalische ursache physische
ursache biologische ursache im gehirn
das ist ganz klar
aber jetzt ist es nicht so dass wir
emotionen zurückführen können auf
bestimmte neuronalen vorgänge anders
gesagt emotionen sind motive realisiert
man das heißt es kann im gehirn eine
region und eine andere aktiv sein es
kann aber immer noch dieselbe emotion
dadurch hervorgerufen werden ist
natürlich immer verlocken zu sagen genau
hier im gehirn sitzt
die ursache ist der sitz von furcht es
gibt hier auch theorie dass ihm
bestimmte angst störungen im
präfrontalen kortex ihren sitz haben
sozusagen
aber natürlich ist darin nicht die
emotionen die emotion ist auch nicht nur
das voll von wohnen das wäre ein
reduktion die dann den phänomenalen
aspekt völlig vernarrt ist aber wir
müssen es natürlich immer eure fragen ja
wo ist die physische biologische
substanz substrat der emotion platz
alternativ wagen 5000 menschen zu
integrieren worauf kann jazz experience
ist an zeit experience is a wall street
ging es im social skills entscheidung
die partikelemission james für flöte
disposition
in praktika smos ihres kannst du das
frühlingskonzert instinkt von das
präsidium ausschütten
also wir emotionen haben ob ihm etwas
mit bewusster erfahrung zu tun
bewusste erfahrung sind nicht immer
notwendig installiert zu lernen also es
geht hier auch über diesen aspekt des
bewusstseins 60 story and social solcher
kalkül consideration us computerbauer
understanding of grey oceans schützt
dieses auto ist interpersonelle von
chelsea helping oben korrigiert
organismen resources communicating
informationen über die griechischen
aufzustellen die transactions
ich glaube dass das auch mich dieser
punkt ist die revolutionäre die nation
und die soziokulturelle dimension von
emotionen zu betrachten
emotionen betrieb nicht immer nur das
individuum das subjekt was ich hat
sondern sie betreffen einen
gesellschaftlichen kontext kontext dem
sie stehen
denken sie mal an die emotion des hahnes
schaan hat schon fast eine art
moralische dimension
wir schämen uns weil wir uns schuldig
fühlen vielleicht auch weil wir uns wenn
wir etwas hat bergen wollen vor andere
als mager revolution geben die nicht
unbedingt jetzt sozial eingebettet sind
weit wäre noch ein ganz klar soziale
emotionen verdankt sie ein verzweiflung
wenn es eine emotion ist ich glaube das
war zwar nicht unbedingt in der
subjektiv fundiert sein muss das wird
zwar gerade auch das kino als individuum
existenziell treffen kann wie es zum
beispiel jetzt heiliger oder noch mehr
kirche kommen argumentieren
also ich bin mir nicht sicher ob diese
zur zu kulturelle dimension für alle
emotionen gleichermaßen von bedeutung
ist in morristown new york an zettel
structural post zu lesen das finde ich
auch ein ganz wichtiger these diese
schlechte opposition von gefühl und
vernunft
die trifft einfach nicht zu emotion ist
der begriff der gefühle unvernunft und
eine einheit
das möchte ich in diesem seminar
deutlich herausarbeiten das können wir
auch anhand der behandelten texte der
bekannten verlosung von 14 8 asse dieses
aufsatzes dieses eintrags emotions can
be a pro creator inspektor date angeles
also können emotionen auch viel gehen
können emotionen übereinstimmen haben
emotionen zu was die eine wahrheits
bedingung könne man zu ein paar oder
falsch sein
das ist eine spannende frage die
natürlich ganz klar emotionen auf die
vernunft bezieht ihren kann eben nur
etwas als rationalen standards
unterliegen
meine these images traces auf des
wissens auf das team ihre situation
rating primitiv und sophistication
information
also es geht hier immer um stimuli und
informationsverarbeitung die kann
primitiv oder elaboriert 2 ich glaube
dass tatsächlich evolution nur eine form
von informationsverarbeitung sind was
wiederum ein hinweis auf rationalität
ist ricola changes in motivation sinkt
ich denke dass das durchaus damit
zusammenhängt motivation und emotion
hängt ganz eng zusammen
denken sie an die bedeutung von
emotionen heraus bewegung bereits im
wort in der bedeutung des wortes emotion
liegt motivation
es hat einen dynamischen beweglichen das
bett ja soviel jetzt zu diesen thesen
und jetzt möchte ich noch ganz kurzen
abschluss der zusammenfassung eingeht
auf eine frage eines teilnehmenden der
letzten sitzung es gibt die medizinische
bezeichnung affektive störung und jetzt
war die frage ist das nicht eigentlich
falsch wenn wir gestört sind sie da
nicht ihr zum beispiel in stimmungen
geschürt
also wenn die depressiv dass sie ihren
keine effekte effekte sind ja nichts was
dauerhaft sensor effekte sind etwas was
momentan tatsächlich habe ich ein
bisschen gegoogelt und bin auf einen
wikipedia-eintrag gestoßen mit wie die
bilder muss man immer ein bisschen
aufpassen liefern zitiert aber für eine
schnelle informationsbeschaffung erster
zugang finde ich es immer hilfreich und
hier steht jetzt bei den hier
diskutierten erkrankungen handelt es
sich streng genommen gar nicht im
störungen von effekten also gefühls
verloren findet interessante übersetzung
oder
zum perfekten seine gefühlswallungen
finde ich sehr sympathisch sein um
störungen der gestimmtheit also stimmung
im englischsprachigen raum wird daher
meist wird dieses wörtlich übersetzt
stimmung erkrankung gesprochen
früher bezeichnete man die erkenntnis
gruppe als affektive psychosen oder
seltener als gemüse gemütlichkeit
getreten auch gut weil es einfach diese
stimmung bezeichnet alle diese tönung
oder färbung unseres erlebnis also eine
stimmung ist nicht so sehr ein konkretes
emotionales erlebnis ein gefühl seine
stimmung ist der rahmen innerhalb dessen
wir die welt unter einer bestimmten
färbung betrachten der 710 ebner schallt
das macht es auch so interessant aber
ich glaube ein bisschen stimmungen von
emotionen und effekt bescheiden also das
noch ganz zum schluss als nachtrag
zuletzt sitzung interessante bemerkung
also angesehen affektive störung ist
eigentlich falsch sollten von einer
horde einer stimmungs störung der
stimmungs erkrankung sprechen